hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the westminster correspondent for
the yorkshire post
jerry scott and the political
commentator jonathan elise good evening
to you both so let's see what's on some
of those front pages now
the observer leads on the sacking of
angela raynor as labour chairman after
the party's poor performance in the
elections
the elections in scotland make the front
of the telegraph with nicola sturgeon
calling for another referendum on
independence
despite the snp falling short of a
majority
but the mail on sunday says the prime
minister is instead urging ms sturgeon
to join
team uk to aid in rebuilding after the
pandemic the sunday express focuses on
boris's plan for a brighter britain
following the conservatives election
success
in england the prime minister will
promise to bring jobs and skills to red
wall areas that have traditionally voted
labour
according to the sunday times
it could cost 960 pounds for covid tests
to go
on holiday which is more than a week's
getaway for a family of four to portugal
according to the sunday mirror
and joining us tonight to take a look
through those papers jerry scott
and jonathan liss thank you both very
much indeed for being with us
jerry we're going to start with the
observer labour's turmoil the
recriminations underway
uh kierstarma blaming the deputy
yeah i mean it's a little bit of a
strange turn of events after he came out
and said yesterday that he was taking
full responsibility but
yes angela seems to have been
unceremoniously
sacked as um party chairman tonight um
and elections coordinator although
she will still remain deputy leader and
you know we uh we're hearing rumors that
other people
may be for the top as well and at least
potentially
john ashworth as well um it's it's i
think it's really difficult actually
for starbuck because sure it's not
unusual for a leader to
do a reshuffle after some pretty dismal
election results but i don't think this
had to be the story for labour going
into
tomorrow they haven't done that badly in
a lot of key races some you know mayoral
races and
we're waiting for the london mayor to
come in as as
as we speak but it's expected that
that'll be you know a labour win
as well so i don't think this had to be
the story of kind of mess and confusion
and
confusion and disorganization going in
tomorrow but that's exactly what it's
going to be
now um and yeah it doesn't really
present the united
party that i think kirsten wanted to
build when he became leader
but not too many months ago really no
and let's talk a bit more about that
confusion and that chaos it is a
saturday
night uh kierstama reacting to those
results but yesterday jonathan he said
he was going to take
full responsibility what does this tell
us about
where he sees that responsibility and
his own role in it
well it's such a terrible look isn't it
to say you're going to take
responsibility
and then the next day unceremoniously
dispatch
your deputy leader who is a woman and is
from the north
uh and obviously uh it's not credible to
play manchester urania for labour's
failure to connect with
voters outside of london and i think
it's also
this idea of a humiliation for rainer
you know she hasn't been
it wasn't presented as a reshuffle it's
sucking
with the consolation prize of another
role in the shadow cabinet but you know
i've spoken to
uh late with sources tonight who say
they're completely
i'm shocked uh gobsmacked is the word
and that's being used because
reyna was not responsible for this um
their the fingers
are pointing at stama's office um senior
advisers such as jenny chapman for
example who've been
kind of responsible um for this dismal
campaign
but you know the same time you know as
you're saying though the story could
have been
about how labour hadn't done um that
badly how the obituaries
are being written prematurely how this
party was leading the polls just four
months ago
and has every chance of reconnecting
obviously the tories found the sweet
spot
with the vaccine roll out and the
economic hit from covid
yet to arrive and so they got very lucky
with timing and
obviously timing is everything in
politics but now the story is going to
be about
confusion disarray and crucially
incompetence
one thing that separates was supposed to
separate the corbyn years
from the starmer era is a kind of
managerialism
a kind of a streamlining a kind of a
competence a rigor
um where everyone knows what they're
supposed to be doing and this kind of
chaotic
message mismanagement is is completely
working against that
yeah and the sunday times uh has uh
it saw it's not its main story but
shaken stammer wields the knife
it says uh it said the reshuffle could
begin as early as
uh tomorrow well it's already underway
but whether or not there's going to be
any
uh rethinking following the backlash
we'll have to wait
and see but it quotes andy burnham who
of course had a thumping
uh victory in greater manchester jerry
and his scarcely veiled leadership
challenge today
yeah he essentially said you know i'm
here and it's not the first time that
andy burnham said this either he's never
really ruled out
running for the labour leadership in the
future
and you know i think he'd be a strong
contender he clearly gets it he gets the
message labor needs to put across and he
was saying
today as well you know that labor can't
keep going into these elections with a
london
centric view i mean it's hyper local but
just in
my own patch of yorkshire um the
homicide pcc election
it was lost by labor to the tories and
the labour candidate there has said we
can't keep going into these elections
with no policies and i think that's
very clearly the message that people on
the ground are trying to give
to labour leadership and i'm not quite
sure
that it's getting through um there's a
real difference
here actually in the way that i think
labor seeing elections especially in the
north in a lot of the areas that i
report on
it's still often seen along class lines
where i really think that what the
tories have captured is people now vote
along much more cultural
lines and labor doesn't seem to have
caught up with that quite yet and they
need to
if they're going to have any chance at
making any inroads in 2024.
and there have been some bright spots
for labor
jonathan in greater manchester as we
were talking about in bristol
and in wales what lessons could be
learned from there
well i think that a big lesson is
incumbency
you know you've seen england scotland
and wales
the governing party um you know building
on a success
either holding it or in fact gaining um
seats
so that's that's something because
obviously in a pandemic people want
their government to do well
uh and perhaps that makes them resistant
to change but i think it's a really
important point about
burnham you know stories about lisa
mandy being sad which i find
completely mystifying because john
ashworth as well these are people who
are doing
good jobs and you also um you know
represent
red wall seats and the the kind of
people that
labour needs to bring closer lisa nandy
it's not her fault that she's been put
for example in in the foreign office
role um which isn't
uh a role this easy to to kind of make
success of
in a front-facing role so i i think that
you know it looks there's the signs are
the labor is actually taking the wrong
message
from these elections and as you say
there are some very promising results
if you care to look for them and that
it's far too early to write off the
party's chances but as jerry was saying
this is not just about economics it's
about culture and labor needs to find a
way
to reconnect with those midlands and
northern seats while at the same time
infusing young people students
people in cities in a way that jeremy
corbyn did let's turn to the sunday
telegraph
jerry and look at scotland now uh nicola
sturgeon falling short just
one short of an overall majority for the
snp
yeah interesting isn't it to say that
it's the will of the country to have
another um
independence referendum when actually
the majority didn't quite put their
faith in that but it was close
so um yes and it looks like if you add
the greeting there is a majority for
independence
she would argue yes well i think i think
i think we're gearing up for a pretty
serious constitutional
battle though aren't we between equal
surgery and boris johnson bobby johnson
clearly doesn't
want this he said it privately and he's
said it publicly and he's twisting the
knife a bit by inviting
both nikola sturgeon and um mark
drakeford to you know
some unions and meetings to save the
union and to keep it
together um but i don't think obviously
this is going to be the last that we've
heard of this
and i think that this is going to be
really the next big fight that
the uk government has on its hands to
try and keep the union
as one jonathan a pretty pointed message
from nicola sturgeon
as well tonight as she talked about we
see what's happening
uh south of the border we want to
secure the kind of country we want to
build but effectively westminster's not
allowing us
yeah and i i really don't think that you
need to be pro-independence
to have sympathy with sturgeon's
position the scottish people have
overwhelmingly
um voted well they've elected a majority
of msps
who support an independence referendum
it doesn't you can't change the goal
post and say that it has to be
a numerical majority of voters you know
by that logic then we'd now
um have a referendum on brexit because
more than
50 percent of voters endorsed remain or
revoke parties in the 2019 election
that's not how parliamentary democracy
works there's now a majority
for an independence referendum how i
don't know how many times
uh the scottish people can ask for this
they it's now been i think the
s p's elected four times in a national
election with this policy
um you know if if the people have asked
for something
it's a duty to give it it's not for the
conservatives to say
you should be concentrating on coving
it's incredibly condescending
the question is really why does the will
of the people only matter
when they're english the union is not a
prison
the founding principle of the union was
its by mutual concept
if you're now telling the scottish
people that there is no legal means to
secede
then that is a very different kind of
union it's one in which the scottish
people are tied
to the uk whether they like it or not
either scottish people have
self-determination or they haven't and
if they haven't then it's very
reasonable for them to ask why they
haven't